I assume your fan base as kids that are
about to be going to college or in
college and they're considering going to
fraternity uh pros and cons of of
fraternity after the fact looking back
you meet some of your best friends you
know those are guys I still talk to
today it's really that good connections
good building it's a lot of fun it made
my college experience a lot of fun I had
people the first week of school when
you're not in anything you don't know
anybody feel like a [ __ ] nerd and
then you like join this fraternity and
you see some guy with your letters on on
the same campus you just Fizz bump each
other what do you mean [ __ ] nerd I
answer me honestly because I know
they're like what is that a nerd you
just felt alone you're just like you're
on a big campus there's 40 000 people
going to this University and you know
your roommate and maybe your ra who's
definitely a narc smells like eggs
you're like I don't want to be friends
with these guys so you're walking around
this campus you see all these people
having fun and high-fiving everybody
like whoa how do I get that how do I get
to high fives and people to like a high
society in public before class
everyone's like who the hell is this guy
he just high-fived a senior and then
three years I'm like I'm burnt out this
is not a sustainable life so I don't
need Natty lights for breakfast